[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a hong kong martial
arts action comedy film called snake in
the eagles shadow spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
the snake fist clan specializes in the
snake style of fighting in kung fu for
the past hundred years the snake fist
clan has had a rivalry with the eagle
claw clan that specializes in eagle
style fighting the eagle clan has made
it its mission to kill each and every
single member of the snake clan and
remove the style of fighting altogether
at the beginning of the movie one of the
last surviving members of the snake clan
is challenged by shang kwan an eagle
claw master the two battle using their
respective styles of fighting but the
eagle claw is evidently more powerful
than the snake fist shang kwon vows to
kill his opponent and end the snake
fist's legacy however it is revealed
that a snake fist master named pay is
still alive shenghuan kills his opponent
and goes on in search of his final and
only opponent pay
meanwhile pay is living a low life as a
beggar he hardly earns any money and
lives off of scraps one day while he is
sleeping on a hammock made up of a
single rope someone barges inside the
room and startles him it turns out that
the landlord has brought a thug to
evacuate pay since he hasn't paid the
rent in a month they search around the
room for money but find a snake instead
while they are distracted pay quickly
grabs his rice bowl and a pair of
chopsticks and runs outside he is
surrounded and attacked by a gang using
the bowl and chopsticks pay defends
himself without much effort even though
his opponents carry knives his
chopsticks are able to overpower them
one of the thugs bumps into an eagle
claw member sue chen while trying to run
after pay when the thug describes pay su
chen realizes that they just encountered
a snake fist member but by then pay is
long lost following that we are
introduced to the protagonist of the
movie qian fu he is an orphan adopted by
a short-tempered eccentric kung fu
teacher named lee lee profits by
scamming innocent students promising to
be a kung fu expert when his skills are
merely average he frequently abuses
chien foo physically and makes him do
all the cleaning jian fu wants to learn
to fight but even though he works in a
kung fu school he is never given the
opportunity to train one morning lee is
resting while the students practice as
usual shinfu watches them and tries
mimicking their movements forgetting to
sweep the floor lee notices and hits him
with a stick to trouble the kid even
more he walks around with white powder
under his shoes which means he has to
sweep the floor twice later lee uses
shan fu as a prop to teach his students
a new form of fighting he orders qian fu
to not dodge the attacks and beats him
up as an example this is not the first
time he has used qianfu to make himself
look like a kung fu expert cianfu is
frequently beaten up but he has no other
way to make a living the only person who
sympathizes with him is the school's
cook and even offers to apply medicine
to his wounds somewhere else pay ends up
in front of another kung fu school in
the town and decides to take a rest
inside a wealthy businessman and his
overweight son lap ban have come to
check if the school is good enough for
lap band's admission the head teacher
boasts about his trainees being the best
in town but lap band is not convinced he
asks a student to break a stack of three
bricks with a single blow the student
does as told and manages to break them
all but as soon as he is out of lap
band's sight he yells in pain while
holding his hand that is now starting to
turn blue moments later lap band tries
to shake his hand and realizes that he
was only pretending to be tough the
father and son leave to get admission to
lee's school instead after that the
students see pay resting outside and
take their frustration out by beating
him up pay doesn't defend himself afraid
that someone might notice his presence
cianfu sees this and stops them from
hurting the poor old man when the
students attack him pei uses his tricks
to make shin fu fight he stands behind
shinfu and pushes him around so that he
can dodge the attacks during the fight a
russian religious missionary notices pay
and rushes towards him in reality he is
a spy who has been appointed by the
eagle claw clan to find and eliminate
the last surviving member of the snake
clan pay notices him and runs away with
shin fu before he can be caught
following that cianfu brings pay to the
school and makes tea for him he also
asks the old man to stay the night
because he must be injured pay is
impressed by his kindness meanwhile lap
ban and his father are in a meeting with
lee who boasts about his training lap
band doesn't believe him and asks him to
break three stacked bricks lee laughs at
him stating that he can show them a real
fight instead of mere brick breaking he
calls chen fu and orders him to take the
beating from one of his students an
excited lap band watches as the fight
begins cianfu is beaten up yet again but
he cannot dodge the attacks scared that
he will have to starve the next day by
the end of it lap ban is impressed by
cianfu's opponent's skills and agrees to
take admission to the school cienfu
walks back to pay with several cuts and
bruises on his face embarrassed he runs
to his room the cook tells pay that it
is a daily thing for shinfu to get
beaten up he is used as a display dummy
to maintain the school's reputation to
lighten his mood pay places a bowl on
his head and asks him to try and get it
jianfu does his best but pay is so
skilled that he doesn't let him get a
single touch of the bowl the following
morning cianfu wakes up to see pay is
missing he notices a message on the wall
that vaguely talks about the dodging
skill outside pay has also drawn a
pattern of footsteps for qian fu to
follow and learn the tricks from
yesterday in reality the tricks were the
basics of the snake fist technique using
the message and the steps chienfu
comprehends what pey is trying to teach
him and starts practicing he is a gifted
fighter and learns the technique in a
short period of time somewhere else pay
bumps into the russian missionary and
follows him to find out his true
intentions however he soon realizes it
is a trap when sue chen of the eagle
claw stops him and challenges him to a
fight the missionary and su chen go
against pay but he manages to flee after
tricking them however he is left
severely injured after the commotion at
the same time lap band's father comes to
the school to check his son's progress
lee asks chiang fu to take beatings from
lap ban wanting to use him as a dummy
yet again but this time using pay's
techniques shinfu dodges all the attacks
he even makes lap band bump into his
father making both fall to the ground in
the end lap band and his father run away
to the other school an angered lee hits
chiang fu repeatedly for humiliating him
cianfu runs away from the school and
coincidentally bumps into an injured pay
he takes him to a shed and dresses his
wounds somewhere else sue chen meets the
higher official of the eagle claw clan
shang kwan and tells him everything
about his encounter with pay then we see
chiang fu taking care of pay until he
gets better after finding out that
shinfu is able to learn the technique
only through the drawings pay agrees to
train him in snake style kung fu his
only condition is that cianfu won't call
him master won't use the training to
display violence and won't interfere
when pay is fighting his opponents
shinfu accepts all the conditions and
starts the training he works hard day
and night and learns the techniques in
no time over a few weeks pay gives him
more difficult tasks but he shows growth
and perseverance like no other one day
he is lazily sweeping the floor in the
school when lee sees him and decides to
trouble him as always he steps on white
powder but before he can step on the
floor shinfu slides them off under his
feet lee tries his best to trick jianfu
but he is quicker because of the
training as they are struggling a group
from the rival school barges in the
leader of the group is the new three
province's champ in kung fu he is
furious because all other schools in the
town sent him gifts to show respect but
lee didn't do so hence he challenges lee
and his fellow teacher to a match lee is
reluctant but since all his students are
watching he has no choice but to accept
the state champion doesn't waste time
before beating them both up proving that
they are just a bunch of frauds who only
know basic knowledge about kung fu jian
fu wants to help them but since he has
promised pay that he will only use his
skills for defense he stays out of the
fight after the two are defeated the
students follow the state champion to
the rival school later that day cianfu
is cleaning when the former teacher of
the school master hang returns from a
trip he used to be the head teacher
until lee took over enraged that they
were defeated by the opponents he walks
to the rival school and challenges the
state champion they get into an intense
fight both matched in skills but in the
end the state champion beats master hang
and doesn't stop attacking him chinfu
finally steps in which angers the
champion even more he attacks him a
couple of times asking him to fight back
now that shienfu can use his training as
defense he doesn't hold back and starts
battling him everyone is shocked to see
that a mere janitor is giving the state
champion a hard time master hang is just
as surprised because he didn't know
cianfu could fight from the entrance
door shang kwan is also watching them he
sees cianfu's technique and recognizes
it as the snake fist technique since
only one person from the clan is still
alive he is sure that shin fu knows pay
after defeating the champion qian fu and
hang return to their school at home
cianfu finds a letter by pay that says
he will be gone for a few days alongside
the letter is a book on snake style
fighting cianfu rushes to the shed to
see pay but the old man has already left
just then shang kwan who has been
tailing him until now inquires if he
knows pay when chienfu confirms shang
kwan lies about being pai's friend and
asks shan fu to tell him when he returns
from his trip he also emphasizes to keep
his arrival a secret from pay because he
wants to surprise his old friend a naive
cianfu believes him and agrees to help
him upon reaching home he sees his pet
cat fighting a snake even though at
first glance the snake looks more
dangerous it is proven to be weak
against the cat's paws this gives cianfu
an idea to mix the paw technique with
the snake fest technique to make it more
dangerous somewhere else pay returns to
the town and is immediately confronted
by su chen at first su chen pretends to
be dead and then attacks him with a
knife he believes pay was stabbed but
turns out he was ready to dodge the
attack they get into a fight where pay
overpowers him with his expertise and
kills him following that he goes to meet
chien foo who is overjoyed to have him
back they ask the cook for tea but the
man mixes poison into it just then
chianfoo remembers shenquan and rushes
to tell him about pay's arrival but when
they return looking for him pay has
already fled shanghuan predicts where he
is heading and runs after him as chien
follows them on his way cianfu is
stopped by the russian missionary who
wants to kill him they get into a fight
where the missionary has an upper hand
because of his sword cianfu gets his
clothes torn but still manages to defeat
him in the end somewhere else pay meets
shenkwon he has had enough of running
and wants to fight to put an end to the
century-long rivalry between their clans
the fight starts and initially they seem
to match in expertise but shenghuan soon
overpowers him and is about to kill him
before cianfu interrupts them to save
his master he asks shang kwan to fight
him instead pay tries to stop chan foo
knowing that he is not trained enough to
defeat shang kwan but he doesn't back
down soon they launch at each other and
chen fu immediately manages to scratch
his opponent's face with his new
invention the cat claw technique by the
mixture of the snake fist and the
catclaw he creates a unique deadly
technique that defeats the eagle claw in
no time in the end shang kwan is also
defeated as the master and student are
about to leave the cook approaches them
and tries to stab qianfu pay stops him
effortlessly and inquires why he is
doing this it turns out that he is also
a spy from the eagle claw clan he laughs
knowing that they are about to die of
the poison he gave them earlier but
shianfu reveals that he had exchanged
the tea because it was too hot in the
final scene the cook remembers that he
drank the poisoned tea the poison's
effect starts to show and he dies
instantly in the last scene pie
complements cianfu for inventing such a
powerful new technique remember kids we
have a lot to learn from cats and if the
tea is too hot don't drink it subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching